[Music]
in high quality taste buds news now that
I'm here hi I immediately think of my
weed they've ruined the word submitted
by Bart's nipples nipples that are
smiles are really cute like it when you
cross your arms into it it's funnier
legit what are the cutest symbols of our
symbols are bigger than the areola so
cute yeah you know me me and Tim have
the same size no no no did you compress
the same size tins are a little bit
darker at this time a new study says 74%
of Americans consider themselves to be a
foodie a hundred percent that sounds
like Yelp to me yeah this is about that
sounds about Yelp what what what is it
ordained foodie well like what is enough
special [ __ ] foodie I think you also
have to be a really good like a foodie
you have to know how to cook as well
like you have to don't have everybody's
like self-proclaimed
cuz just cuz you like to eat I don't
know if that's a foodie well my my might
I don't know if like foodies name now
you know real world word first of all
let's start with that right I think if
you really like food you have to cook
because you can't sit there and judge
what somebody else does in the kitchen
but you don't even know what the [ __ ]
goes on in there yeah so a lot of the
times people will come up and though you
still write these reviews right they go
well be clearly they use this in that
you wouldn't [ __ ] know you've never
made the dish yourself so how do you
know what this sort authentic is to
which I [ __ ] hate but I agree with
that and I also think your palate has to
be white yeah you can't say you love
music and you only listen to pop music
exactly I go from classical to country
to whatever and I think if you only eat
like in and out or something you're not
really a foodie you can't just like
burgers you gotta like everything we
consider a foodie yeah if you're if you
just like burgers and you're just like a
burger connoisseur
yeah initially when the word came out I
always thought foodie meant like you
like to try different things from
different places that's initially what I
thought it meant I just met you love
food yeah
see the dictionary of foodie or if there
is a definition for foodie because I
don't know what it means
foodie a person with a particular
interest in food
a gourmet a gourmand like I'm thinking
likes people like oh yeah I'm a foodie
when they're like Yelp the best
restaurant when they go somewhere and
then they just go and just take a
picture of the food history of it but
like you're not really into the there's
layers yeah you gotta know the flavor
you gotta know how it's made you gotta
know like the history behind the food
the culture it's like dots of foodie
that's true just taking a picture for
the gram and be like I'm a foodie I
think most people just like to eat these
are ten signs of foodie oh yeah I would
enough own foodie I'm not frequently
trying new foods nope that's me Atlas
that's very me being interested in food
origin no yeah that's very me I [ __ ]
Wikipedia foo for hours 92 like four
[ __ ] hours
that's crazy I'd like to know where it
comes from because when I eat it I'm
like it's almost like this National
Geographic like diagram look oh yeah if
something goes oh my god I think I just
made the connection between Korea and
this and that and whatever and I'm like
okay he doesn't say please ok next one
being able to cook a quality meal I'm
okay I don't know about that that's the
biggest key for me I've made quality
meals having an awareness of what foods
are in season yeah Florence depends yes
because you know like our grocery store
always has [ __ ] 24/7 so we're not really
on that seasonal tip like we used to be
it is though like your grocery store oh
yeah that's true
what do you mean your fruits and your
veggies like it's based on season like
you don't have every fruit available
yeah there's a lot of things that we
ship from South America and things like
that that we shouldn't what we do yeah
this is really bad taste yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ]
yeah you're right like fall apples and
stuff yeah yeah yeah next one is knows
how to pair cured meats with cheeses
wine in beer that's hard though that's
good
and I gotta give a pass on Talent
sometimes I thought that should be the
requirement for food it should be that's
true I thought that you want to commit
boys not yeah that's one thing I'm
missing I just know what the cheese I
like I got one point taken off ready
yeah well I like cured meats
I love cured meats I just don't know
like girl and the bucket we with the
whatever me for like should you just
made up on the spot yeah
all right next one is always have a
restaurant you should try oh yeah
Oh like a list like if people come into
town or whatever or like when you travel
you're like we gotta try this
[ __ ] right here I got a list of
those I like to consider myself like a
Jonathan Gold
who the hell is that what you're not
John you don't know who that is and then
they fight I don't think gold is like
the father of like so he's the dude that
put these hole-in-the-wall rush passed
away recently to recipes he put these
hole-in-the-wall restaurants bottom
white guy yeah he looks like bro like on
like a chubby white dude Oakland he
looks like the [ __ ] a Sonic the
Hedgehog a villain like that's what he
look like he does he does remember we
watched I don't know what what TV show
we were watching totally delicious
he looks like he makes pizza all the
time which one was it oddly delicious Oh
probably Jonathon gold does look like
the Sonic the Hedgehog villain you are
small right yeah
so Jonathan gold is a guy that literally
put fine-dining restaurants not to be
the fancy napkin [ __ ] but bomb-ass food
hole-in-the-wall spots so he actually
was one of those people that put asian
food on the map because people would a
considered asians who fine dining you
know but so recently I just went to a
stitch one restaurant called me an and
yet diary after my I moderate the spice
but they had a Jonathan cold start he
put that [ __ ] on the [ __ ] last time
so if you even now if you follow the
follow the Instagram you see all of his
favorite restaurants are these plots
that aren't fine-dining
quote-unquote with the fancy napkins and
so to me that's like the rush yeah it's
just the food is just [ __ ] good you
know I mean you don't need this [ __ ]
five-star whatever chef to come in you
know I mean you just need to eat the
food and say yo this is unique and this
is good that's it
I like those another
our sign of a foodie is being able to
pronounce difficult food names I think
they even got that prosciutto I just
liked it oh shoot Oh next one is eating
healthy what I do know there's a lot of
food that's not healthy ingredients I
say like healthy fresh ingredients and
that's the ingredients yeah healthy like
very last one is having travel to a
country to try their food oh yeah we do
that all the time it's a losing way we
travel yeah is to eat so you guys are
probably you're you're probably foodies
on fish yeah I'm wait who did you guys
meet all the requirements I got like one
or two points seven or eight out of ten
just in bread and though to consider
myself I don't think anyone either
not a single one I don't care for like
weird people that don't know go [ __ ] if
I'm pretty nice like food I don't know
what that means we don't eat because we
love the pleasure when you eat something
has it ever made you feel so good you
want to just punch someone in the
stomach yep like he's one growling
school clothes yeah but not enough for
me to be like I [ __ ] love food I need
food every [ __ ] food sugary food them
I don't really water you like you like
Japanese food I do like I deliver a
restaurant not really
Morton's mue drawing blanks now cuz now
the pressure
you know feels 20 have a family of food
like Mexican food they love Mexican food
I love Japanese food I love Taiwanese or
like you know northern China cuz I know
I don't really like Hong Kong like
Cantonese stuff yeah you don't like the
stir-fry snails name like eagle claw
[Laughter]
I'll leave it I love it like Indian food
- I was like wait you can't see that
white yeah so yeah I mean there's like
different cuisines I like but there's
nothing where I'm like I'm not doubt
this [ __ ] yeah what in the [ __ ] that's
so wild to me man it's crazy because we
all have different experiences like we
all share the physical realm but then
like the Wow what we are our senses you
know like from what we see yeah it's
taste and everything is so different
like I could eat this [ __ ] banana and
be like this is the most amazing thing
in the world someone else could eat it
and say this is [ __ ] [ __ ] or I
would eat it I'm just like it's a banana
my sense if your guys's this taste my
sense is sounded oh for sure she is
straight-up this sounds like that
shit'll move me the way me I could have
like much people cousin like this shit's
[ __ ] awesome for me I could have like
the worst day in the world and I could
say I eat a ball of cinnamon toast
crunch it could just change my day
no that's ice called milk I'm just like
that's how it is for me life is worth
living when I go to sleep the things I
do right before I go sleep is always
look up new recipes new restaurants and
food so I didn't say jerk off
yes no that's not it I think you're a
real foodie foodie
I like food I don't wanna be I don't
wanna be proving important is food porn
he said that before yeah but you know
like legit like I would be like on my
iPad and I was it Muriel I can't prove
biggie was Gina Gina she said what are
you looking at and I'm like what do you
mean she started be what's important
it's like like this recipes is [ __ ]
because I was like salivating oh yeah
so this article here it was this survey
that was conducted with 2000 Americans
who offered the percept that respective
perspectives thank you on their
appreciation of food and so they found
that 74% of Americans claim that they
have a sophisticated pet palette 56 of
them consider themselves a foodie 30
most Americans have their taste
awakening at the age of 31 really wow
they're saying that for only 14 percent
of those aged 55 or older reported that
they feel they have a very sophisticated
palate compared to 36% of survey
respondents of aged 18 to 24 56% of
Americans reported that learning about
the history and origins of certain foods
actually helped them enjoy it even more
a hundred percent I think I knew my
first enjoyment of food in elementary
school and with the cafeteria food when
I just saw like the kids when they get
the burgers right and they opened the
ketchup packet and they just squirt it
on they just eat it oh my [ __ ]
amateurs you got to do it in a [ __ ]
circle put the bun on and then twist it
so it's nice and even that's a good one
and then I bite into it on my you guys
never know anything about deprived
sardius child it was that mom pat him
like carrots in like lettuce or
something you'll remember what we went
to [ __ ] was a banana bay or some [ __ ]
oh my god was like dude this Thai food
is like [ __ ] macaroni and cheese with
like hand cues and like pickles or some
weird [ __ ] up dude this [ __ ] is Bob she
sounds really good yeah it's actually
bad because I'm gonna go eat some shoes
I'll take you to some real places that
place I used to go when I was in high
school I was high all the time so no
wonder tasted really good
he ordered this [ __ ] it came out and it
was I would have remember to the beat
[Music]